AND TOOLS OF SOCIAL CONTROL.
THEY BECOME ILLEGITIMATE AND
SCARY END OF THIS CASE OUGHT TO
MAKE YOU NERVOUS.
JOHN BRENNAN RAN THE CIA UNDER
MSNBC WHO INSULTS DONALD TRUMP
AND ADVOCATES FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
HE NO LONGER WORKS FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN ANY
CAPACITY, HE HOLDS NO OFFICIAL
POST AND YET ACCORDING TO TWO
SOURCES WE SPOKE TO EXCLUSIVELY
TODAY, HE RETAINS PERHAPS THE
MOST VALUABLE ASSET HE HAD IN
GOVERNMENT -- A TOP-SECRET
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
THIS ALLOWS HIM TO DO WITH THE
REST OF US CANNOT DO, VIA A
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS AND DISCUSS
WITH INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS ARE
STILL WORKING IN GOVERNMENT AND
LICK THAT INFORMATION TO THE
PRESS.
THIS IS AN AWESOME POWER, OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES KEEP
AMERICA'S MOST SENSITIVE
SECRETS.
THEY HOLD HIGHLY PERSONAL
IT IS TERRIFYING TO THINK HE
STILL HAS ACCESS TO ANY
INFORMATION.
HE IS AN OUT OF THE CLOSET
EXTREMIST.
THIS WEEK, HE ACCUSED
DONALD TRUMP OF TREASON, A DEATH
PENALTY OFFENSE.
HE SUGGESTED IT WOULD BE
REASONABLE FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES TO CONCEAL INFORMATION
FROM THE PRESIDENT -- THAT'S A
VIOLATION OF THEIR CHARTER AND A
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW.
TWEETS DIRECTLY TO THE PRESIDENT
LIKE A CRAZY PERSON.
EARLIER THIS YEAR HE WROTE THIS.
YOU COULD ALMOST HEAR HIS
FINGERS SMASHING THE KEYBOARD,
NOT A STABLE MAN.
HE IS A PASSIONATE IDEOLOGUE
WITH A DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF
DISHONESTY.
THE CIA DIRECTOR HE LIED ABOUT
SPYING ON SENATE STAFFERS AND
KILLING CIVILIANS WITH DRONE
STRIKES.
HE LIED ABOUT THE STEELE DOSSIER
FAMOUSLY.
HE PREVENTED THE CIA FROM
REFERRING TO ISLAMIC MILITANTS
AS JIHADISTS.
IF THIS IS NOT A MAN WHO SHOULD
HAVE SECURITY CLEARANCE.
WE CALLED TO ASK IF HE HAS
REVEALED CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
OR IF HE'S PAST INFORMATION TO
HIS COLLEAGUES ON NBC, THEY DID
NOT RESPOND.
DISHONESTY WHO RETAINS A
GOVERNMENT SECURITY CLEARANCE.
IF JIM KLAPPER APPEARS TO HAVE
12, THE SAME WITH MICHAEL HAYDEN
A FORMER CIA DIRECTOR.
HE RECENTLY SUGGESTED THE
PRESIDENT IS CARRYING OUT A
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WINDS UP
IN THE MEDIA ON A DAILY BASIS,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY THIS
AND BOLSTER THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, NOW YOU HAVE SOME SENSE.
YOU WOULD HATE TO THINK THAT
DEEP STATE IS REAL, THERE IS A
PERMANENT GOVERNMENT THAT
OPERATES INDEPENDENTLY OF VOTERS
SENATOR RAND PAUL REPRESENTS THE
COMMONWEALTH OF KENTUCKY, HE IS
WORRIED ABOUT THIS.
WE TALKED TO HIM ABOUT IT A
SHORT TIME AGO.
JOHN BRENNAN IS AN IRRESPONSIBLE
PARTISAN COMBATANT WHO WORKS FOR
A CABLE NEWS CHANNEL AND HAS
THREATENED THE PRESIDENT ON
TWITTER.
WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD HE HAVE A
TOP-SECRET FEDERAL SECURITY
CLEARANCE?
>> THIS IS ALARMING.
DONALD TRUMP?
AND HE RESEARCHES FAMILY, KENNY
TYPE MY NAME INTO COMPUTER
SEARCH ENGINES, CAN HE LOOK AT
PRESIDENTS -- IT'S ALARMING.
IF HE HAS SECURITY CLEARANCE
IT'S ALARMING.
>> Tucker: WE SPOKE TO
WE TRY TO CONFIRM IT WITH THE
COMMENT ON THAT, WE BELIEVE IT
TO BE TRUE.
WHAT WOULD PREVENT HIM FROM
SPEAKING TO CURRENT EMPLOYEES OF
THE CIA OR OTHER INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES AND GETTING SECRET
INFORMATION FROM THEM THAT COULD
BE LEAKED TO THE PRESS ARE USED
AGAINST HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS?
>> HE HAS A HISTORY OF LEAKING
INFORMATION ALREADY, NOT ONLY
FOR POLITICAL REASONS BUT A FEW
THAT PERSON WAS STILL ON THE
BACKPEDALED AND THEY HAD TO
RESCUE SOMEONE OUT OF YEMEN WHO
PROBLEM WITH LEAKING, WHO IN THE
RIGHT MIND WOULD WANT TO LET HIM
HAVE THE POWER STILL TO SEARCH
THROUGH EVERYBODY'S RECORDS?
>> Tucker: HE'S A PRIVATE
CITIZEN WHO WORKS FOR A CABLE
CLEARANCE AND FIND OUT
GOVERNMENT SECRETS AND USE THEM
IN THE COURSE OF MY JOB?
>> I THINK IT'S COMPLETELY CRAZY
AND THE IDEA THAT HE COULD BE
NOT ONLY TO THE PRESIDENT ASKING
IF HE STILL HAS CLEARANCE WHICH
I THINK THE PRESIDENT MIGHT BE
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE.
I'M SENDING IT TO JEFF SESSIONS
AND DAN COATS, WE ARE GOING TO
PRESS THE CASE AND WE ARE GOING
TO FIND OUT DOES HE STILL HAVE
CLEARANCE AND SHOULD A PERSON
WHO HAS CALLED THE PRESIDENT
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT JUST
BRENNAN, IT IS POTENTIALLY END
WE BELIEVE IT IS ALSO JAMES
CURRENT PARTISAN WARFARE,
STUDENTS THERE BE SOME MECHANISO
PREVENT THEM FROM ENGAGING IN
PARTISAN WARFARE?
>> JUDGES GRANT WARRANTS SO THEY
WOULD HAVE TO GO TO A JUDGE TO
GET PERMISSION TO LOOK AT THE
DATABASE.
I DON'T WANT THEM RESEARCHING
DONALD TRUMP'S POLITICAL
SUPPORTERS, THE WAY TO STOP IT
IS TO HAVE OVERALL REFORM AND
I'M GOING TO TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT ON MONDAY.
WERE GOING TO ASK THE PRESIDENT
WILL YOU INSTITUTE A NEW RULE AT
FOR AMERICANS MATERIAL WITHOUT